a big fan of bathroom graffiti love it
sometimes I find it can be a bit cruel
for my tastes though it's reading this
one bit of graffiti recently it said
Andrea is a [ __ ] found that personally
offensive because my mom's name is
Andrea I was in my parents bathroom
I was like come on dad talk to her if
you're upset just scroll your feelings
on the wall like an animal guys I don't
go in much for theories about kids these
days but I will say this kids these guys
have it too good with their boy bands
I'll explain what I mean
nowadays every boy bands like One
Direction it's all cute guys back in my
day a boy band was mostly cute guys plus
one creepy old dude you had to put up
with that was a boy band oh you like the
Backstreet Boys you like Nick and Brian
well here's Kevin yeah Kevin's 45 got a
wife and kids notice anything about
Kevin's shoes sensible Kevin was like
the skull on the edge of Shakespeare's
desk just reminding us all that this too
shall pass sometimes if the lead guy and
a boy band was cute enough he came with
two sad sack pieces of [ __ ] well you
like NSYNC you think Justin Timberlake's
dreamy yo he comes with Joey Fatone and
Chris Kirkpatrick
yeah hope you like your dream boats
through the side of a pizza shop owner
and a walking talking pineapple guys I
don't expect you to remember what Chris
Kirkpatrick looks like with doing
yourself a favor and Google them and
then immediately Google a pineapple and
just play spot the difference is let's
put it this way if chris kirkpatrick
ever robbed you and then ran into a
produce aisle you'd be like well it
could be any one of them want to pin
this on the wrong pineapple guys up in
canada i am not only a famous comedian
I'm also an acclaimed rapper which I
understand that there was a guest
earlier on the show who was also a
rapper I'm assuming it was the guy named
urban anyways I have a hit single that's
making waves across the continent and
you will recognize that you'll know the
words so don't be shy I want y'all to
sing along can you hit that beat please
that's right ladies and gentlemen this
is my hit single y'all know the words
don't be shy all of you lame ass rappers
back down my rhymes are so tight you
could call it freaking like an eagle if
y'all don't like it you can eat
[Music]
not making a sound if I had your lyrics
I be on the Oh cuz that's how I roll on
the baddest rapper since oh yeah I'm the
greatest rapper in addition to some oh
yeah I'm the greatest person dangerous
man got a mic in my hand and I come in
my
and the ladies love me cuz I get my on
there that's why they call me wizard
okay response y'all know how this works
it's like when I say because my rhymes
are tender like like like that's how you
know that my name is
[Music]
made that pretty clear
[Applause]
you